in the last couple of videos we talked
about a reflection and that's just the
idea of the light rays bouncing off of a
surface and if the surface is smooth the
incident angle the incident angle is
going to be the same thing as the
reflected angle we saw that before and
then and those angles are measured
relative to a perpendicular so that
angle right there is going to be the
same as that angle right there that's
essentially what we learned in the last
couple of videos what we want to cover
in this video is when the light actually
doesn't just bounce off of the surface
but starts going through a different
medium so in this situation we will be
dealing with refraction refraction or a
fraction you still have the light coming
into the interface between the two
surfaces so let's say so let's that's
the perpendicular right there actually
let me continue the perpendicular all
the way down like that and let's say we
have the incident light ray coming in at
some at some angle theta-1 just like
that what will happen and so let's say
that this up here this is a vacuum light
travels the fastest in a vacuum in a
vacuum there's nothing there no air no
water no nothing that's where the light
travels the fastest and let's say that
this this this medium down here I don't
know let's say it's water let's say that
this is water all of this this is all
water over here this was all all vacuum
right up here so what will what will
happen and actually that's kind of an
unrealistic well just for the sake of
argument let's just say that we have
water going right up against vacuum this
isn't something that you would normally
just see in nature but let's just let's
just think about it a little bit
normally the water since there's no
pressure it would evaporate and all of
the rest but for the sake of argument
let's just say that this is a medium
where light will travel slower what
we're what you're going to have is is
this Ray it's actually going to switch
direction it's actually going to bend
instead of going continuing to going in
that same direction it's going to bend a
little bit it's going to go down in that
direction just like that and this angle
right here theta two is is the
refraction that's the refraction angle
a refraction angle or angle of
refraction this is the incident angle or
angle or angle of incidence and this is
the refraction angle once again against
that perpendicular and before I give you
the actual equation of how these two
things relate and how they're related to
the speed of light in these two media
and just remember once again you're
never going to have vacuum against water
the water would evaporate because
there's no pressure on it and all of
that type of thing but just do before I
go into the math of actually how to
figure out these angles relative to the
velocities of light in the different
media I want to give you an intuitive
understanding of not why it bends
because I'm not telling you actually how
light works this is really more of an
observed property and light as we'll
learn as we do more and more videos
about it can get pretty confusing
sometimes you want to treat it as a ray
sometimes want to treat it as a wave
sometimes you want to treat it as a
photon but when you think about
refraction I actually like to think of
it as kind of a as a bit of a vehicle
and to imagine that let's imagine that I
had a car
let me draw a car so let we're looking
at the top of the car so this is the
passenger compartment it has four wheels
on the car and looking at it from above
and let's say it's traveling it's
traveling on a road it's traveling on a
road on a road the tires can get a good
traction the car can move pretty
efficiently and it's about to reach an
interface it's about to reach an
interface where the road ends and it
will have to travel it will have to
travel on mud it will have to travel on
mud now on mud obviously a tires
traction will not be as good the car
will not be able to travel as fast so
what's going to happen assuming that the
car is that the steering wheel isn't
telling it to turn or anything the car
would just go straight in this direction
but what happens right when what with
which wheels are going to reach the mud
first well this wheel this wheel right
here is going to reach the mud first so
what's going to happen there's going to
be some point in time where the car is
right over here
where it's right over here where these
wheels are still on the road this wheel
is in the mud and that wheel is about to
reach the mud now in this situation what
would the car do what would the car do
now assuming that you know the engine is
revving and the wheels are turning at
the exact at the exact same
a speed through at this you know the
entire point of this the entire time of
the simulation well all of a sudden all
of a sudden as soon as this wheel hits
the medium it's going to slow down this
is going to slow down but these guys are
still on the road so they're still going
to be faster so the right side of the
car is going to move faster than the
left side of the car so what's that
going to happen I mean this is you see
this all the time if the right side of
you is moving faster then the left side
of you you're going to turn and that's
exactly what's going to happen in the
car the car is going to turn it's going
to turn in that direction and so once it
gets to the medium once it gets to the
medium it will now travel it will now
turn from the point of view from the
cars turning to the right but it'll now
travel in this direction it will be
turned when it gets to that interface
now obviously light doesn't have wheels
and it doesn't deal with mud but it's
the same general idea when I'm traveling
from a faster medium to a slower medium
you can kind of imagine the wheels on
that light on this side of it closer to
the vertical hit the medium first slow
down so the light turns to the right if
you're going the other way if you are
going the other way if I had light
coming out of the slow medium so let's
imagine it this way let's have light
coming out of the slow medium and if we
if we use the car analogy if we use the
car analogy in this situation the left
side of the car is going to so if the
car is right over here the left side of
the car is going to come out first so
it's going to move faster now so the car
is going to turn is going to turn to the
right just like that so hopefully
hopefully this gives you a gut sense of
just how to figure out which direction
which direction the lights going to bend
if you just wanted it intuitive sense
and to get to the next level there's
actually something called Snell's law
Snell's law
Snell's Snell's law and all this is
saying all this is saying is that this
angle so let me write it down here so
let's say that this velocity right here
is velocity - this velocity up here was
velocity one going back to the original
actually let me let me draw another
diagram just to clean it up and also
I've got that vacuum water interface
example I'm not
enjoying it just because it's a very
unnatural interface to actually have in
nature so maybe it's vacuum in glass
that's something that you actually would
exist so let's say we're doing that so
this isn't water this is glass this is
glass let me redraw it and I'll draw the
angles bigger so let me draw a
perpendicular and so I have our incident
our incident ray so in in in the vacuum
it's traveling at V one and in in the
case of a vacuum it's actually going at
the speed of light or speed of light in
a vacuum which is C or 300,000
kilometers per second or 300 million 300
million meters per second let me write
that so C is the speed of light in a
vacuum and that is equal to 300 it's not
exactly 300 I'm not going to significant
digits is true to 3 significant digits
300 million meters per second this is
light in a vacuum light in vacuum and I
don't mean the thing that you use to
clean your carpet with I mean an area of
space that has nothing in it no air no
gas no molecules nothing in it that is a
pure vacuum and that's how fast light
will travel now it's traveling really
fast there and let's say that this is
and this applies to any two medium but
let's say this is let's say it gets to
glass here and in glass it travels
slower and we know for our example well
the this side of the car is going to get
to the slow medium first so it's going
to turn in this direction so it's going
to go like it's going to go like this we
call this v2 and maybe I'll draw it if
you wanted to view these as vectors
maybe I should draw it as a smaller
vector v2 just like that and the angle
of incidence is theta 1 and the angle of
refraction is Theta 2 & Snell's law
Snell's law just tells us that the ratio
between V 2 and the sine remember
sohcahtoa basic trig function and the
sine of the angle of refraction is going
to be equal to the ratio of V 1 is going
to be equal to the ratio of V 1 and the
angle of incident a sine of the angle of
incidence sine
beta1 now this looks confusing all we're
going to apply it a bunch in the next
couple of videos but I want to show you
also that there's many many ways to view
Snell's law you may or may not be
familiar with the idea of an index of a
refraction so let me write that down
index of refraction index or a fraction
index and it's defined and it's defined
for any media for any material there's
an index of refraction for a vacuum for
air for water for for any material that
people have measured it for and they
usually specify it as n as N and it is
defined as the speed of light in a
vacuum that's C divided by that C
divided by the velocity of light in that
medium in that medium so an ark in our
example right here we could rewrite this
we could rewrite this in terms of index
of refraction let me do that actually
just because that's sometimes the more
typical way of viewing Snell's law so I
could I could solve for V here if I one
thing I can do is just if n is equal to
C divided by V then V is going to be
equal to C divided by N and you can I
can multiply some both sides by V if you
don't see how I got there the
intermediator step is multiply both
sides times V you get V times n is equal
to C and then you divide both sides by n
you get V is equal to C over n so I can
rewrite Snell's law over here as as
instead of having V 2 there I could
write I could write instead of writing V
2 there I could write the speed of light
the speed of light divided by the
refraction index for this material right
here so I'll call that n 2 right this is
material to material 2 right over there
right that's the same thing as V 2 over
over the sign over the sine of theta 2
is equal to is equal to V 1 is the same
thing as C divided by N 1 over sine of
theta 1 sine of theta 1 and then we
could do a little bit of simplification
here we can multiply both sides of this
equation well let's let's do a couple of
things
let's actually the simplest thing to do
would actually take the reciprocal of
both sides so let me just do that so if
we take the reciprocal of both sides of
this you get sine of theta - / / c n2 is
equal to is equal to sine of is equal to
sine of theta 1 over C of C over n1 and
now let's multiply the numerator
denominator of this left side by n2 so
if we multiply it n2 over n2 we're not
changing it this is really just going to
be 1 but this guy in this guy are going
to cancel out and let's do the same
thing over here multiply the numerator
and the denominator by n1 so N 1 over N
1 that guy that guy and that guy going
to cancel out and so we get we get n 2
sine of theta 2 over C is equal to is
equal to n1 + 1 sine of theta 1 over C
and now we can just multiply both sides
of this equation by C and we get the
form of Snell's law that some books will
show you which is the refraction index
for the slower medium or for the second
medium the one that we're entering times
the index of the sign of the index of
refraction is equal to the refraction
index for the first medium times the
sine of the angle of incidence the
incident angle so this is another
version right here this is another
version right there Snell's law let me
copy and paste that and if this is
confusing to you and I'm guessing that
it might be because if specially if this
is the first time that you see it we're
going to apply this in a bunch of videos
in the next few videos but I really just
want to make sure I really just want to
make sure you're comfortable with it so
these are both equivalent forms of
Snell's law one deals with the
velocities directly deals with the
velocities right over here the ratio of
the velocity to the sign of the incident
or refraction angle and here it uses the
refraction in the index of refraction
where the index of refraction is really
just tells you it's just the ratio of
the speed of light to the actual
velocity so something where light
travels really slowly we're like
travels really slowly this will be a
this will be a smaller number and if
this is a smaller number this is a
larger number and we actually see it
here and you're going to see a little
tidbit of the next video right over here
but here's a bunch of index refraction
indices for different materials it's
obviously one for a vacuum because for a
vacuum you have the refraction index is
going to be C divided by the speed of
light in that material well in a vacuum
it's traveling at C so it's going to be
one so that's where that came from
and you can see an air the speed is only
slightly smaller this number is only
going to be slightly smaller than the
speed of light in a vacuum so in air you
still it's still pretty close to a
vacuum but then for a diamond it's
traveling a lot slower it's traveling a
lot light is traveling a lot slower in a
diamond than it is in a vacuum anyway
I'll leave you there we're gonna do that
in a couple of more videos we're going
to do more examples using Snell's law
hopefully got the basic idea of
refraction and in the next video I'll
actually use this graphic right here to
to help us visualize why why it looks
like this draw got bent